today on the podcast
we're highlighting the power of open
educational resources
or oer i
love using oer one thing i love about
teaching oer is that i get to teach
what i want to teach what i think my
students need to know
in the way they need to learn it instead
of just defaulting to what the textbooks
say in this episode i invited two
instructors in to talk about open
educational resources
one of them teaches negotiation and
management here at mit
and shares her course materials in mit
open courseware
the other recently adapted those
materials for use in her own course at
another university
an organizational ombudsperson at mit
for 42 years
adjunct professor mary rowe was among
the very first instructors to put her
course materials on opencourseware
almost 20 years ago that course is
titled 15667
negotiation and conflict management
associate professor elizabeth seiler has
used and adapted the materials from this
course
in her teachings at worcester state
university
when we brought these two instructors
together something really special
happened
while much of the conversation did
center on negotiation
itself mary and elizabeth simultaneously
began a real real-time collaboration
about how to teach negotiation with oer
from mary's course
the conversation brought forward so much
of what we at ocw
hope oer can do for educators you know
things like creating community shared
ownership of learning materials and
fuel for inspired teaching that we just
really wanted to share it with you
we hope it will help you find new
inspiration for using oer in your
teaching
so without any further ado let's jump
into the conversation
you'll hear me talking with elizabeth
first and we start with one of my own
insecurities about negotiation
and anxiety some of you may share
when i think about negotiation i like
freeze up i'm like oh god i have to
negotiate a salary i'm never
going to get what i want i can't ask for
what i want well that's one of the
reasons that i really like this
course learning it and teaching it it's
one of the things that this is probably
true for most students
and most people they don't really like
to deal with conflict
but learning about negotiation is a way
that you can
learn that there are different ways to
handle a conflict or handle a
negotiation
without changing your personality right
without being something that you're not
you know it's their skills and their
behaviors but they're not
personality traits you know you can be
shy and still be
clear in what you want and ask questions
you can still be a successful negotiator
and still not like speaking in public
i think that's a wonderful example of
how negotiation specialists try to build
options which is that those who
get into negotiations about anything
including bedtime for children
want to come up with options
i'm taking that to heart as i think
about my three-year-old tonight
[Music]
so the course 15667 the one we have on
mit open courseware it involves a number
of case
studies and simulations which you've
made openly available
mary to the world tell us about the role
of
case studies in the course so case
studies and discussing real life
is how you learn negotiations it's
absolutely essential
there's one of them called dealing with
an aggressive competitive negotiator
and this was a case the main characters
named mr canny and he just
wants what you're selling but he won't
admit it and he won't give in and he
won't you know he keeps asking for more
and
i mean he's a real pain but um what i
love about this is that it
the students read this and they're like
ah what do i do this person how do i
deal with this person what's going on
you know
and then they talk about it with each
other and they start to see that okay
there's some things we could do
and then we start to apply the process
of well what are his interests right
what does he want
what's going on behind the scenes you
know he's being very aggressive
but why is that and what does he like
and how might you talk to this person so
he'll be more likely to
take you seriously and
so the two things i like about this is
one is that the
teaching notes for some of these are
really thorough and lovely and wonderful
is this list that's like two pages long
of things that you could do
to address the situation but the other
thing about it is that
this is written so strongly that
my students had some really visceral
reactions to this
some of them got really felt really
angry we did this at the end of the
class
the end of the semester so that they
were more comfortable talking about
they're more comfortable with
self-disclosure about how they were
feeling and what went on
and some of them got really angry some
of them got really scared
you know um i was thrilled when
you know this very articulate very kind
of cool hockey player guy in my class
said
i'll admit it you know i was a little
nervous when i was reading this
like yes okay good
um and so they could talk about how
you have to deal with your own emotions
right before you can go on and negotiate
which in business so much emotions are
treated like they are
bad or that people don't have emotions
but you can't really negotiate well if
you're
afraid you know or you can't negotiate
well with somebody if you're angry
so one of the things we talked about at
the end is okay here's how you felt
about this what are some things that you
do
i mean there was money involved in it
but the thing that was really important
about that one to me was to get the
students to
acknowledge their emotions and figure
out how to deal with them and then to
see that
there's a whole lot more things they
could do in the situation than they
thought of than they had thought about
before
it's hard to imagine elizabeth a more
skillful
discussion of teaching that case
uh listening to you i'm i notice
two things one of them is that you've
illuminated
perfectly that we're all negotiating
with ourselves
and how we're dealing with our
negotiation with our our dealing with
our emotions
um we've got two different points of
view i've got to make this work
and i'm panicked or i'm furious so
you're opening up a discussion at the
end of the class
about even not just
how i notice that negotiations are
important
i guess this should have been my first
point is that emotions are important
that after all relationships between
people
are almost always the most important
thing going on even more so than money
but secondly that in dealing with my
emotions that i might be
negotiating with myself i loved your
description and i love how you can tie
that back to the theory
right negotiating with yourself because
uh
well that's frankly that's one of the
hardest things i find about teaching is
until i really really know like until
i've taught the course a lot or really
know it it takes me longer to make those
connections
from the student experience to the to
the theory
so it's really helpful to see that well
and it's helpful to me to listen to you
and see it
so always learning
[Music]
listening to elizabeth again now
reminded me
of how every student who role plays
has a chance to learn
their own strengths and their own
vulnerabilities
and i think that could be elucidated
better in the teaching
i used to say at the beginning of the
course that i have no idea whether we
can teach people to negotiate
better in the sense of getting more of
what you want i was pretty sure
that we can teach how you and your team
can lose less in working with other
people
i'd like to think more about that in
revising the course
we haven't actually proven that we can
teach people to negotiate
better in part because how well you
negotiate
is for you to decide and i can't tell
you
how you would think of it you might
watch me negotiate and think i'd given
up the store
and i'm pretty happy about it because
i've maintained the relationships that
mattered to me
but i think we can teach people to
defend themselves better
and that we can prove that anyway you're
right on the fringe now of
what i've been thinking about
the case studies in 15667 are designed
for graduate students in the mit sloan
school of management
and many of these students come to the
course with previous management
and business experience my students have
not had the same kinds of work
experience that a graduate student would
have so i went and added some things in
to explain well
this is how a law firm works or this is
what a defense contractor does and this
is the way the organization is
structured so when you say this this is
what it means
when it says this this is what it means
it's just really helpful because that
that's the stuff that they would need to
know to make a decision but they don't
need to know it to
learn how to negotiate i try to get the
confusing things out of the way
so they can concentrate on what are the
interests
you know and how what am i going to say
very good ideas
it seems like you're touching on an
important aspect of what it means to
teach with oer
what it means to really discover
something and then to change it to make
it work for
your students yeah i love using
oer one thing i love about teaching oer
is that i get to teach
what i want to teach what i think my
students need to know
in the way they need to learn it instead
of just defaulting to what the textbooks
say and sometimes that means using a
textbook that's
an open resource and just adding things
in sometimes it means pulling from
more than one textbook sometimes it
means pulling things from
writing things and pulling in podcasts
and articles and
and the newspaper from newspaper from
yesterday right
i asked elizabeth if she had any tips
for educators who wanted to begin
teaching with oer
the first thing i would do is to talk to
your librarian
because librarians are pretty much at
the forefront of
open education resources the next thing
i would say is to find somebody to work
with
find some community which is mary's
nodding
it's a lot easier if you were starting a
course kind of from scratch
the way i was with this course to find
somebody to work with because it
helps split up the workload and it gives
you somebody to bounce ideas off of
and the other thing is just to think
about
what you what's working and what's not
working about your correct course
because if something's not working you
can probably find something else to
replace it
it's not just about using a textbook
that's free so that your students will
have it
it's also about being able to teach what
you think they need to learn
the other thing is that if you're using
open educational resources
that you can mix and match there are
several
meta search engines for oer materials
right now
and you know the good news is the bad
news that there are so many of them you
might have to dig through to find what
you're looking for
but the good news is that there is a lot
out there
and if there's not then you can write it
elizabeth what plans do you have
to share the materials you've adapted
uh from mary's course with
others right that's part of open
education resources overall
is community again and it's doing what
you have and sharing it with other
people
once i finish i'm probably going to work
with the instructional designer at my
school
actually to put things in a word
document and pdf document so that
they could be in a format that's can be
easily
adapted by other professors and then
find a platform
for it before we ended our conversation
i asked mary and elizabeth if there was
anything else they wanted to ask
each other about teaching with the oer
in 15667
well i would like to ask elizabeth did
you use the task of writing a
perceived injurious experience yes i did
i the reason that i ask is that of
everything that i ever stumbled into of
course everything you've
heard from me is hindsight i never had
the wit
to plan it but of everything that i ever
came up with
in teaching negotiations the perceived
injurious letter
and various variations of it flew by far
the furthest
i would get requests i remember one from
canada to reproduce
the instructions in 500 000 copies for
school for a elementary school or
something
and still on my website at sloan
it's now called ideas to consider if
you've been harassed
right but basically the notion of how to
deal with a situation where you
have felt injured or or hurt
so i'm very interested in your
experience with it yeah for one of the
last
assignments in the semester the students
could write the perceived and juris
experience experience right they could
write a pie letter or they could write
an apology letter
they could choose and they could write
about something from themselves in their
own life
or they could write about something from
one of the cases because not everybody
has the same level of comfort and
disclosing and that's fine they can
still learn
and what i found out was first of all i
was really
surprised still even with being around
you know hundreds of undergraduates
every day
just how much how personal people were
willing to get
at this i mean it it was clear they were
i was the only person who was going to
read this nobody was ever going to do it
they didn't have to send it
but people got really personal and i
thought they would be getting personal
more about how they'd been injured but
they got really personal
and really explicit and really
thoughtful about how they had hurt other
people
and that was really powerful i mean like
i was
i was kind of blown away by how willing
they were to take this on and the things
they said
and i wish i had done it earlier in the
semester so that i could find out some
more
you know how did they react to that like
what did they get out of it
going back to the beginning of this i
think that maybe why this spoke to me so
much it's because
it was everything every day and that
there are a lot of things you can do in
business classes with a very
low amount of emotions involved you know
and that's great
but this isn't one of them and we don't
really talk about it much in any other
business classes
but we're human as my finance professor
said annabelle burrell and she said we
are more than rational beings
right and i think this is one of the
places where that's incredibly clear
you remind me also that it's the basis
for leadership
to the extent that management training
includes a discussion of leadership
emotions and relationships are
profoundly
fundamental you to have completely
changed my perspective
on what negotiation is i feel like
you've created
a pathway for me to explore this area
more i feel like it's accessible to me
that i might actually
be good at it that i might be doing it
already
without knowing it
[Music]
if you're getting the same feeling that
maybe you or your students might already
be
or could become good at negotiation with
the right tools
and want to learn more you can explore
download
reuse and remix all of mary's teaching
materials from our mit open courseware
website
on our website and in the show notes
you'll find the case study about dealing
with an aggressive competitive
negotiator like mr canny
and guidelines for writing a perceived
injurious experience letter
if you like elizabeth use these or other
oer from opencourseware in your teaching
we'd love to hear about it because when
you share your story
of using oer you inspire others and
that's what we're all about
thank you for listening and we hope you
enjoyed season one of chalk radio
we're already hard at work on season two
if there's a professor you'd like to
hear from
reach out and let us know until next
time
i'm sarah hansen from mit open
courseware
you